what do you say mom when you read in the
papers that you are determined
domineering woman i don't always read
that people are willing to tell me that
but i don't think i am i'm a
perfectionist with myself but not
necessarily with everybody else those
stories arose a long time ago and have
kept coming out again and again but i
don't think i am you feel hurt by them
well obviously one does you feel very
wounded and if it comes out you think oh
gosh i don't want to go out and do my
engagement somebody wants to see me help
panic but you've got to push yourself
out and remember some people hopefully
won't believe everything they read about
you because there's far too much about
me in the newspapers far too much
horrifies me when there's something more
important like what goes on in a hospice
or there's been a bomb or something
they'll put me on the front page need
motivation what's the top 10
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best princess
diana and my take on her top 10 rules
for success
enjoy
rule number two use your pain to help
according to
press reports
it was suggested that it was around this
time things became so difficult that you
actually tried to injure yourself
is that true
when no one listens to you or you feel
no one's listening to you all sorts of
things start to happen for instance you
have so much pain inside yourself
that you try and hurt yourself on the
outside because you want help but it's
the wrong help you're asking for people
see it as crying wolf or attention
seeking and they think because you're in
the media all the time you've got enough
attention inverted comments
but i was actually crying out i wanted
to get better in order to go forward and
continue my duty and my role as
wife mother princess at wells
so i uh yes i did inflict upon myself
i didn't like myself i was ashamed
because i couldn't cope with the
pressures
what did you actually do
well i just hurt my arms and my legs
and i work in environments now where i
see women doing similar things and i'm
able to
understand completely where they're
coming from and in a way by being out in
public they supported me although they
weren't aware just how much
healing they were giving me and it
carried me through rule number three
serve you were struck
first by the hospices weren't you yes
but particularly when when you first
went into one or did you sense about it
i'd always been led to believe that it
was a possibly unhappy place because
patients went in there and not always
did they come out
so it was fascination on one side and
concern on the other
and certainly after i'd been around the
first ward i remember it so vividly i
was struck by the calmness coming out of
the patients in their bed
and
most of them
will
have gone by now obviously
and it was confronting
their illness they were so brave about
it and made me feel so humble i feel
underdressed
rule number four do what you love how
did you actually come to be at the
kindergarten in the first place well it
was through friends
i wanted to teach children they said why
not come along so i first started often
afternoons
and then i took over the mornings and
did whole days
but i only worked three days a week
kindergarten and the other two i looked
after american baby boy which nobody
seems to realize
who was very special to me
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five be grateful you see
i've got two very healthy strong boys
and it's not always the case with the
families i'm meeting through dr
barnardo's and i realize how incredibly
lucky i am and i don't know how i could
cope if i had a child that was
handicapped or mentally handcuffed in
some way so for me i'm going out there
to meet
these children and i'm learning all the
time
and trying to understand trying
desperately to understand how they cope
rule number six empower others isn't it
normal not to be able to cope all the
time
isn't it normal for women as well as men
to feel frustrated with life
isn't it normal to feel angry and want
to change a situation that is hurting
perhaps we need to look more closely at
the cause of the illness
rather than attempt to suppress it
to accept that putting a lid on powerful
feelings and emotions
cannot be a healthy option
that to offer women the opportunity to
explain their predicament sooner
could be a far more effective use of
limited resources
rather than wait until their strength to
survive
has been sapped
as long as the real reasons for their
problems go unnoticed and unattended
they will continue to pass on to the
next generation their disability
[Music]
if we as a society continue to disable
women by encouraging them to believe
they should only do things that are
thought to benefit their family
even if these women are damaged in the
process
if they feel they never have the right
to do anything that is just for
themselves
if they feel they must sacrifice
everything for their loved ones
even at the cost of their health their
inner strength and their own self-worth
they will live only in the shadow of
others
and their mental health will surely
follow
but if we can help to give them back
their right to fulfill their own
potential and to share that with their
family children or friends
maybe
fewer women would find themselves living
a life that is bleak beyond belief rule
number seven commit fully you are
developing your own interests and your
own specialization
yes but that's taking time because i
don't want to dive into something
without being able to follow it up
nothing would upset me more than just
being a name on a top piece of paper and
not showing any interest at all
hopefully the organizations i'm involved
with see me
two or three times a year if the times
you know i can i can do it i can fit it
in
um i just
belong to help in all sorts of areas
rule number eight always keep learning
you've also taken up
the deaf
yes and you're learning the deaf and
dumb
side language well i'm trying i'm pretty
hopeless at that but
i think it's important to show them that
you're interested and you're not just
breezing in and out having seen them for
a morning i've got all my senses
and they haven't they're missing one or
two
and
i'm learning how how they adapt or if
they've been deaf and dumb since birth
how they cope and how they deal with the
outside world who don't always want to
know about them perhaps
do you practice the language does the
prince help you with your lessons
i don't know if you'd understand
i knew one romance
that
h h and you know why because when i when
i had my tonsils out when i was very
small i had a night nurse it was called
sister hicks
she always used to come and say his
sister
so i always remember that it doesn't get
me very far i'm afraid in my
conversations with the dead
but i look forward to her teaching me
thank you rule number nine be selfless
those women who have taken on the heavy
burden of attending to others
need also to be attended
not just for their own sake
but for the good of us all
health and happiness taken at the cost
of others pain and suffering cannot be
acceptable
women have a right
to their own peace of mind
each person is born with individual
qualities and potential
we as a society owe it to women to
create a truly supportive environment
into which they too can grow and move
forward
but if we are to help the quiet
desperate lives live behind closed doors
by so many women
they need to know for certain that they
are not alone
that real support and understanding is
there for them and rule number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is be supportive i feel my role is
supporting my husband
and whenever i can and always being
behind him
encouraging and also
most important thing being a mother and
a wife
[Music]
and
that's what i try to achieve whether i
do is another thing but a good try
it is sometimes argued that addicts
bring their problems on themselves
but i've noticed that those such as
turning point who have first-hand
knowledge of what these problems really
are seem less inclined to pass judgment
instead
i suggest that we consider what part we
can play in the fight against addiction
whether as a parent
a friend
a colleague or an employer
i know that today's conference will
concentrate on drug and alcohol problems
but i should also mention turning points
work in the field of mental
health as more mental patients leave
hospital to join the community there
will be increasing demand on turning
point services
the charities three mental health
projects help ex-patients make the
transition from the institutionalized
life of a mental hospital
to a more normal existence in the
outside world
for people who have been in hospital for
as long as they can remember
learning to fend for themselves can be a
frightening experience
even the simplest tasks such as
understanding money or using household
appliances may have to be learned from
scratch
this is an area of growing demand and
turning point has received many requests
from local authorities to extend its
services for the long term mentally ill
mental health like the problems of drug
and alcohol misuse does not easily
attract public sympathy
there are many charities which campaign
for more appealing causes
in overcoming this disadvantage turning
point has developed an initiative
approach to its work
typified by this joint venture with a
major brewery
i believe that whitbread and turning
point are to be congratulated for their
initiative
which is just one example of the charity
strategy of building a strong
partnership with industry and business
to help fight drug and alcohol problems
at work
now in its 25th year turning point faces
greater challenges than ever before
its partnerships with government and
industry offer much hope for the future
conferences such as today's will i'm
sure make valuable progress towards the
elimination of drug and alcohol problems
at work
but just as turning point believes these
problems must be tackled on a
painstaking and individual level so we
in turn must recognize the part that
individuals can play in caring for all
the casualties of our society
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see the
top 10 we did on oprah winfrey check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there everybody that i had
on the show at the end of the show would
say something to me like
um
is that okay you will find true success
and happiness
if you have only one goal